the connection between dog and man it's
a beautiful thing
[Music]
wow
dog flying bear you're missing it
can you jump that high
whoa I believe in you
I believe in your ability to jump 23
feet
pancake dog yes
beer it's a pancake dog
oh that's so me and she's saying eat in
Russians that's actually not a pancake
that's a a bleen chick
two dog goes
being frozen still three dog goes Frozen
still
why are they frozen though they're
freaking me out a little it seems like
they're frozen in time oh they're just
well behaved all goes that's why God I
love well-behaved doggos the connection
between dog and man it's a beautiful
thing oh he just punched me in the face
wow
he's straight mugging me I don't want
your paw I don't
[Music]
look at this little thing she says I
want it I love it bear you need a
brother or sister or a cat
what's your point now booby
oh the doggy tried to get a rabbit I've
never seen bear interact with any other
animals outside the species I would be
so curious to see how he would with a
rabbit bottom line is we need to get a
dog for protection like if someone tried
to break into our house I'd want to make
sure that they were immediately
terrified what is that
okay I did not expect that I think if
people bring it to the house bear would
just be like what's up can you pet me as
long as you pet me I'll show you where
all the valuables are right new
let me inlay a fall
I know how to react oh I would make that
my phone background if I was that dog
owner
this is a dog that is being shot that's
bear that's lit bear this is you man
you're this long look how long bear is
we have a dog with a bird
oh is a dog gonna eat the bird don't eat
the bird oh my God are they best friends
bear what would you do if I got you a
bird like this
[Music]
bear wants nothing to do with this bird
okay it's a border collie that's
standing there wanting the statue to
throw in a toy for some reason this is
awesome
that's not a real person border collie
that's also a dog with great manners
just saying kiss
laughs
kiss oh
someone's getting the scratchies yeah
bear you like to scratchies you like to
scratchies
whoa mouths when they don't want to hurt
something that was insane can I take
your head and fully
ew
oh look it's it's you bear
how is that dog not freaked out
oh there you go scare that bear away oh
that's a dog that doesn't want to go
somewhere
well I feel sometimes when I go to work
[Music]
Saint Bernard is just like I'm messing
this pool up sorry man dogs sometimes
make the biggest mess completely
accidentally Bears floofy tail over
there knocks over everything in the
house including lights
okay that's not real
hold on a second I think I could mimic
that ready
okay we got a house a ring camera of
some kind
knock knock package
oh the dog went through the glass that
is one excitable animal things I haven't
been able to do since owning a German
Shepherd sleep properly because the
German Shepherd takes up the entire bed
not have dog hair on all clothes and
mouth and food finishing a yogurt by
myself sure have a peaceful shower true
bear always likes to barge it into the
bathroom have any type of wallpaper oh
why does the dog eat the wallpaper
that's strange basic daily chores oh no
see bear doesn't like the vacuum that's
a young German Shepherd too and I
wouldn't say these are only things for
German shepherds I think this is for all
pups
oh my God a Yorkie found dentures
that is so gross for so many different
reasons
they definitely did that on purpose come
on oh that's a diesel dog oh my God is
that normal for a dog to be that
muscular I feel like that's a dog that
goes to Gold's Gym and maybe those
creatine protein and anavar and
clenbuterol okay too many things
our first children's hospital visit oh
see this is what my dream for Bear was
but then the coveted pandemic messed it
all up oh
supporting paws are the way to go tell
me you wouldn't want a giant bear to
come hang out with you Smiles are
important optimism is important and dogs
bring all of that
we couldn't forget about the nurses yeah
honestly everyone stops working when a
dog comes in to any kind of employee
environment a little bit of trivia all
my podcast guests so far have pretty
much universally loved bear the person
who loved the most probably Barbara
Corcoran she asked for Barry to slobber
all over her outfit and I was surprised
because it was a fancy outfit
oh doggo
taking a bath
in a little cubby why do dogs love water
so far I remember I would take Roxy to
the dog park and she would literally run
to where the puddle was and lay down in
it
oh that's a cutie that's a good trick so
that when you do it like this the dog
just runs into the hole
I do the same thing but with touch touch
there you go okay we have a
uh this is not how I bathe bear because
bear does not fit in a giant tub
human-sized let alone a sink but this
already looks clutch oh it's so cute
it's so easy to look how little it is
yeah dogs love chasing air I don't know
why they just like oh my God look at
that little face and you could shape it
too I've also tried grooming bear with
kitchens shears and that failed
miserably I got called out by all these
dog groomers so now I have proper dog
shears you ready to show off oh is the
dog gonna show off
how's the dog gonna show up
sliding around on the ice spot
oh it's in Newfoundland
I'm just gonna scooch in right here if
you don't mind oh my god when bear steps
on you like that you gotta remember
these dogs have big dew claws that
really hurt if they catch you because
like they're super sharp down here you
can't even see them because it's like
buried in his fur
okay going for a walk
oh that's a shoulder dislocation I can
diagnose it right then and there by the
way tip for dog owners that with dogs
that pull keeping a shorter lead or a
leash meaning like holding it closer to
the dog's neck will remove that slack
and therefore remove the ability of the
dog to really get a running start and
have all that momentum to pull you and
hurt your shoulder
that's a Frenchie that loves sticks it's
a great way to bring a dog home oh honey
you're stuck oh bear used to get stuck
like that too so did Roxy ow yeah like
watching them navigate stairs or go
through hallways doorways they
constantly
oh
so resilient they're like yeah I'm gonna
make it through it'll be fine it's like
watching Roxy hobble around on three
legs it's sad but at the same time she's
still so happy oh no way this dog knows
how to blow
there's no way bear would do that I
could not trade him to do that
doggy hi doggy oh it's a fake doggy
what's gonna happen is a dog gonna freak
out oh no is it gonna get scared oh no
don't scare your dog most dogs wouldn't
get scared by it they would not smell it
so they would not be worried except
maybe that little one poor doggy its
brain is just short circuiting because
it recognized it in the visual cortex
but then in the old factory area it's
like no it's not there
I've tried doing this with bear he's too
heavy he's too uncomfortable to pick up
I don't know how to pick him up like
that in fact I need a video of how this
dog owner picked up their Newfoundland
like this
oh no way this is real is this real do
they do this for dogs vets let me know
do dogs get breathing treatments like
this I can't imagine dogs sit still for
this
God I don't think I can live in that
home
whenever I would take Roxy to the park
dog park and not let her go in because
she was not behaving she was pulling Etc
and I would sit on the outside until she
would calm down she would be screaming
like that and people thought I was
abusing her just because I wasn't
letting her go into the dog park you're
so vocal
so many of you asked how I groomed this
monster of an animal well click here to
get that answer and as always for me and
the new stay happy and healthy
[Music]